it's my pleasure to be here on this
magical night what a gorgeous place to
host this event
it will be indeed very special for
the folks who will be inducted into the
hall of fame for sure and i'm sure that
the players are excited because last
year
everything was online and this year we
are back
to playing chess over the board dr
jeannie karen singh failed and rexing
felt if you don't know it you are in a
room of people who are so grateful to
you
and what you've given and what you've
provided them so it is beautiful to be
here tonight where you are honored they
are
clearly
the longest serving and largest
benefactors that u.s chess has ever had
and a lot of the success that us chess
has as an organization and many of its
best players is because of their active
involvement the reason we are here
tonight is also the reason the
gateway city has become
the gateway to chess
genie and rex simple
i knew from our first conversations
that rex didn't just want his name
on a building or a trophy
it was clear he wanted to do that most
important thing of all
to make a difference
this is a real honor to be inducted in
the world house hall of fame
given that i am
in this crowd and i am the only unrated
chess player
okay so and the final thing is i want to
thank all the chess lovers and the chess
players
the guys who are out there and the
people who are lousy players like me
basically because it's been so much fun
you're actually making it possible for
us to continue
to do and i want to thank you for this
honor i want to tell you how
appreciative i am of being married to
the
godfather of american chess i had the
idea of the chess club but i never would
have imagined what it has become
when i first heard that i was being
inducted into the hall of fame i thought
of bob euchre the former st louis
cardinal and milwaukee brewer catcher
and current sportscaster comedian and
actor when 2000 was inducted into the
sports hall of fame
he said and i say fellas i really should
have gone in as a player
everyone thank you so much for joining
us for the 2021 u.s championship opening
ceremony and in the induction into the
chess hall of fame
enjoy the evening good night